>> Hello, I'm Heather Kitt and I'm a Global
Change Maker here at the World Economic Forum
on the Middle East. I think the concept of
role models are incredibly important as it
cultivates imagination and as Einstein said
"imagination is more important than knowledge".
It inspires us to look beyond our own circle
and aspire to be more and role models kind
of put the pin in the map. The show that it's
possible. However, creating role models is
a very difficult thing. There's no, there's
no, you can't make sure the role models that
you create people will pay attention to. In
inspiring youth, young people will choose
whoever they want as a role model and this
is quite dangerous in the sense that they
can be an ineffective role model. In the United
States and the UK for example, Eminem, a rapper,
is a very influencial role model. However,
he talks about hitting his wife and you know
shooting people. Is this the kind of role
model we want to create? And Therefore what
the question I would like to propose to you,
is how can we ensure that positive role models
have the positive influence that we need?